halo 5 Guardians Microsoft book ended
their show with halo and gears award
their big for first party franchises
halo 5 guardians on the show right now
from 343 industries joining me chris and
kevin guys big show for you yeah we're
really excited to be here to show up
what is the most ambitious Halo game
we've ever made so it's a big show well
I mean Halo games have really been short
on ambition in the past so that's not
saying a lot we always like to push the
boundaries yeah for sure yeah seriously
and you guys showed off that campaign
during the press conference of course
show it off to four different
perspectives different characters and
then war zone i believe on display as
well that's right war zones are a big
new multiplayer mode it's 12 on 12 with
everything in the halo sandbox in one
place everything in the halo sandbox in
one place that is a lot of things let's
start by talking about war zone a little
bit because I'm a huge halo multiplayer
fan I love the way the sort of movement
is as powerful as the weapons but like
let's give the overview of war zone
everything is a lot of things what do
you got we have AI bosses which are sort
of upgraded AI characters from the
campaign that have a really unique
personalities and the players can team
up to go after those okay so that's like
a cooperative endeavor that's right yeah
when you're spawning you can go after
enemy players after basis or after
bosses wait oh that's all in the mix
yeah and we also have every weapon in
every vehicle that's offered in Halo 5
all in one place so it's really
fantastic how it sounds like it's got to
be kind of a big place oh absolutely
we're dealing with maps that are four
times larger than ones we've previously
had in Halo then like the typical
multiplayer map that's right yeah so if
you think about Halla think of four of
them together for of it together just
man cannons all over the pan did he
build the deluxe meant like end-to-end
man cannon I don't have an end-to-end
man can we have a ton of man caves on
the map to help with player movement for
sure yeah I mean you you build the scale
up that much it just kind of I imagine
it multiplies exponentially the kind of
flow decisions you have to make the kind
of like enemy deployment weapon
placement kind of stuff you gotta deal
with absolutely we also have to think a
lot about vehicle paths
and one of our biggest surprises was
when we scaled up the masses munch we we
ended up with way more air space so that
really opened up all the air combat
where we're featuring the Banshee and
our new vehicle to fate on the Phaeton
that's right that's nice it was that we
got a glimpse of that in a trailer we
did it's a forerunner Promethean beetle
is sort of like a hovering vehicle that
just rains death on players soundly
might be kind of fun to fly I think I
could get behind that yeah you'll get a
chance on the show floor today excellent
what we're taking a look at now is the
campaign demo you guys showed off at the
microsoft press conference and of course
showcasing one of the things that I
think then I'm certainly most intrigued
about for this campaign is the the
return of a sort of a foursome of
specific characters that are sort of
voiced and with you a significant amount
of the time yeah it's actually more like
an item if that eight so yeah we have
two Spartans squads in the game the one
that we showcased in the media briefing
was a fireteam Osiris which is led by
Spartan Jameson Locke yes and he has
with him Spartan Olympia Vale who is a
linguistic expert who came from the Navy
Spartan Columbia Vale sounds like the
most badass codename for something
mysterious and also by the way I don't
know Olympia veil oh it better be avail
we have a holly Tanaka who survived the
glassing of her homeworld and she came
from the army so she's this tough
Spartan in the squad and we have our fan
favorite Edward buck oh look been minted
a Spartan after playing through ODST he
became a smart in the Spartan floor
program there is taking down a veto
there goes that dates on there's one of
the most interesting things that you
guys at 343 have done with the whole
Spartan the idea of a Spartan that now
yeah you can become a Spartan you don't
have to read in a vat you know I not
that they were bred and bats we don't be
like abducted as a kid and then become
this weird sort of Master Chief level
Spartan it sort of gives you guys a lot
more freedom to play with personality
yeah and to play with this dynamic of
through the core conflict of halo 5 this
dynamic of sort of
the future of the Spartan program and
what we want it to be versus what it was
which is something you touched on in
Halo 4 but is now back in a big way yeah
you get to really experience that a lot
in the game because while we do have the
Spartan force which are you know some of
the best of the best from each branch of
the military we have the Spartan tues in
the blue team with Master Chief so
master chief has linda fred and kelly
from the extended fiction that will be
joining him which is a great really
exciting for our fans who you know they
weren't sure if Fred Linda and Kelly
were actually alive or not they saw in
the eviction but we brought them back
and they're like Chief surrogate brother
and sisters from the Spartan to program
that were abducted so you get to see the
contrast of the two teams as you play
through the game I like the contrast of
soldiers who grew up independently and
then joined the Spartan program their
names versus these kids that we abducted
inmate Spartans Fred Linda the Olympia
bail like Holly Tanaka like this it I
think that the the contrast there
certainly something you know you guys
are sort of leaning into a little bit
which school awesome alright so we're oh
here's the fates on in action yes yep
that is the Phaeton yep and so now this
is a glimpse at war zone like make a
little sense for me of in terms of well
I guess we're hopping between different
stuff I you know what's the goal for
someone who jump into multiplayer and
say I'm gonna go hunting some
Prometheans what's the goal well each
team has the goal of getting to a
thousand points and then your team's
gonna win by getting there so you score
points by killing players capturing and
holding bases and then most importantly
taking down these powerful AI bosses so
just a second I you saw a guy going
after Baroness Rome who has a legendary
boss in war zone and he flies a banshee
around and we get to see these fantastic
combat situations where two teams of
players are going after him at the same
time because he's worth so much and
there's trying to get that last shot in
that's right we also have an alternate
wind condition at war zone where if you
capture all the bases for example you
can see this players in the armory and
the garages in front of him if you
capture them all the enemy team shields
will go down you can take out their core
okay so there's kind of a lot going on
and that's definitely you know in terms
of the
objectives of halo multiplayer
historically have always been pretty
clear pretty focused in terms of you've
either got just kill everything that
moves or you've got achieve this little
objective and also kill everything that
moves but now you guys are really sort
of diversifying the battlefield that's
right we wanted it to be open to all
sorts of Halo players so if you're a
campaign player if you're a rina
multiplayer player if you love big team
battle if you love taking down AI we
just wanted everyone to have something
to do in war zone and let them play
their way if you ran a bunch of Spartan
Ops and that was your chance oh yeah
yeah you're gonna go you can take those
AI killing skills into the competitive
forum that's right super key to winning
the match one thing we did want to make
sure though is that when you're playing
through with all of this choice we spent
a lot of time really working on how the
objectives show up and are presented to
the player so you have a really clear
idea of when a boss is coming into the
battlefield and when your team is going
to capture these bases so while you
can't make a choice to play how you want
to play you always understand what you
need to do on the battlefield I or D is
like where you can be the most effective
toys apparel right when you're designing
something big with so many options you
don't want players to feel lost that's
right and sometimes teams do have to
make a decision though when it's coming
down to the wire it's like do we go
after that last legendary boss do we
hold down these bases or do we try to go
for their core and the players that play
wars on a lot and are experiencing the
depth they're really getting to come to
these awesome battle situations it seems
like you guys have also probably had to
put some serious work into your AI to
like sort of make them function in this
place that has these objectives and has
multiple teams sort of battling it out
is that true oh absolutely because we
also have Marines so when you ever you
capture one of the bases like the
garages of the armory or your home base
you have marines on your team that are
friendly and will support you so with
dozens of AI running we really had to
upgrade our technology and get
everything on dedicated servers to
deliver this that we use does that mean
that I'm going to be coming into war
zone and killing Marines that's right
for the first time Oh means yep oh it's
dark as all right ones on the enemy team
yes true an enemy's an enemy yeah you
guys are certainly uh breaking down the
idea of what an enemy
is expanding it historically from what
the enemy has been in halo I narrative
Lee I feel like that's kind of a tricky
business because you're taking this guy
Master Chief it's like on a pedestal for
most of the past decade-plus yeah and
really just kind of making it oh hey man
you're not that you're not the guy
anymore well so cheap still plays a
central part in the story of Hale's life
yeah we're continuing on the saga of
Halo 4 but we are introducing the new
fireteam Osiris so you get to play in
the campaign as well as Spartan Locke so
there's a lot of great story there so
you know chief is still a really
important part of the story absolutely I
mean you gotta have chief yeah chief is
chief haha but we're looking at right
now sort of something reminiscent of the
beta you guys rolled out earlier this
year yeah gay people look at the new
Spartan abilities and kind of how they
work in combat then of course during the
campaign demo we saw those Spartan
abilities in play I how's the
development and tweaking and balancing
but coming on those because it's taking
halo combat and adding some
significantly different things in there
yeah so one of the best things about the
beta is we got a ton of community and
fan feedback and so we took that
feedback and we've been tuning all sorts
of things to help improve the experience
for when we launch we've done things
like change the wake or movement speeds
work we kind of removed the top end of
sprint because we felt that was a little
too powerful and then we increased bass
movement to kind of close that gap but
still providing a good tactical option
there we saw that when people were using
our new smart link aiming mode automatic
weapons were too powerful in the beta so
we actually tune that down a little bit
to kind of balance out smartlink versus
hipfire and automatic weapons verse
precision weapons so we've been really
using a lot of that feedback so thank
everyone very much thank you everyone
and providing that because it's been
really helpful in dialing it in and of
course we have our pro team at 343 who
consists of some of the best halo pros
that have played the game and they keep
giving us feedback day to day to help
tune and refine this as we get closer to
launch all right what's current
currently I know I know this is going to
change
guys weekend week out what's your
favorite new Spartan ability to use in
combat what do you like in these days oh
I'm gonna go with shoulder by shoulder
charge yeah Sheldon charge for sure the
shoulder charge yeah because you can get
unbored on you there's some places you
can go through new tunnels you can open
up if you bash through them and also
when you're like running up on an enemy
and you kind of coming around the corner
and you hit in that heart it feels
amazing yeah I love this bar in charge
but I think my favorite is ground pound
where you get to the elevated position
kind of hang in the air it's this risk
versus reward but as soon as you contact
someone did you feel amazing and
everyone in the match goes talks about
it on the headsets and everything in
play test lab feels crazy yeah that's
like the Marquis play right I remember
yeah try that moving few more than a few
times in the beta and had some success
and what I did it felt awesome but also
hung myself out to drive future yeah
more definitely put your selfie miss and
you hit the ground you know it takes a
little while recover from it and people
can help you quite a bit take advantage
of that for sure it's an awesome feeling
when you pull off the ground pound it
absolutely is oh man alright getting the
halo jitters us games coming out later
this year are you guys planning a beta
or anything else a second-round beta
before the game comes out we don't have
a second round of beta but we're still
using all that feedback from the first
beta okay so there won't be an
additional beta before we launch this
year the launch date men launch date is
October 27th October 27 that's halo 5
Guardians Chris Kevin thank you guys so
much for coming on the show I'm talking
about it oh that's gonna be a big one
it's gonna be a big fall this year for
Microsoft
you